E aí
sim
nada na na
[Música]
boa tarde
Vocês estão conseguindo me ouvir não é
obviamente o meu português não é o
português e vocês então eu vou tentar
falar de uma forma que vocês possam
entender o melhor possível é eu sou um
brasileiro de fato e um português de
direito eu sou neto de portugueses
e a minha história no Brasil é muito
interessante porque Eu dividi a minha
vida profissional
em uma parte acadêmica vive em faculdade
sempre de pesquisa é outra parte dentro
de indústrias ou seja tem uma vasta
experiência com relação à parte de
produção a parte desenvolvimento mas e
sempre foi engenharia só formado em
engenharia de Materiais com mestrado e
doutorado na área de biomateriais tá e
eu gostaria de apresentar para vocês
alguma coisa na visão de um brasileiro
com relação a sua interação entre
em Portugal e Brasil
com vistas a questão de colonização e
formação da sociedade brasileira
Uno na verdade o grande grande mentor do
Estado denominado do Brasil foi Dom João
sexto A história nos diz que Dom João
foi um rei que criou uma série de
iniciativas que promoveram o estado
brasileiro como no caso o Banco do
Brasil abertura dos postos indústria
Biblioteca Nacional e principalmente
Academia Militar
a copa
e isso
bom e nós temos um verso que na
realidade é um trecho de uma música de
Chico Buarque que mostra que o objetivo
nosso sempre foi o sonho de cumprir o
ideal que seria se tornar um imenso
Portugal Mas isso não aconteceu o quê
que deu errado
e com a vinda da Família Real ao Brasil
nós tivemos essas questões que foram
indígenas para quem já viviam no Brasil
seja um português emigrante seja um
descendente de português a subir a subir
tá em inflação dos bens de primeira
necessidade
confiscos
imagem negativa da corte pela corrupção
desenfreada
a rainha que na verdade era uma
Imperatriz porque o que na realidade a
rainha era Maria primeira aqui em
Portugal considerada adúltera e aceita
desta forma pela corte e o aumento da
escravatura que nós carregamos um ônus
pesado até hoje
e o amante de Dona Maria em 1816
elevação de seu pai a rei de Portugal e
rompe a revolução constitucionalista de
1820 exigindo que a família real
retornasse a Portugal
ao voltar a Portugal Dom João deixou seu
primeiro filho Dom Pedro primeiro aqui
considerado por vocês como Dom Pedro
quarto
e Entretanto a corte permaneceu não
retornou com Dom João a corte permaneceu
e com relação à parte de
pressão de Portugal com relação às
exigências de exploração e rescisão de
direitos Dom Pedro se a linha essa
história mas na verdade ou ele se
alinhavam ele perde o trono E cria cria
o
Império Brasileiro forma super
brasileiros novos costumes são
delineadas obviamente
o Fernando um povo distinto do povo
português a economia cultura se
desvincular dos padrões de Portugal
Entretanto a corte continua com
comportamento idêntico à época da
família real no Brasil gerando o modelo
seguido pela sociedade brasileira cujos
valores sobreviveram até hoje
e as histórias atuais do Brasil vocês
devem ouvir nos noticiários
e não são nada agradáveis para gente mas
tudo tem um vínculo de 400 300 anos
atrás
bom então brasileiros e portugueses são
povos distintos sim mas extremamente
semelhantes Quais são as distinções
primeiro a miscigenação pelas colônias
que foram ao Brasil principalmente a
espanhola A Italiana EA japonesa
a economia distribuição de renda nós não
tivemos em nenhum momento na nossa
história um processo que houvesse é
concretamente uma melhor distribuição de
renda na sociedade brasileira
ambição indolência é outra questão muito
importante em função da própria
influência da grande massa da escravidão
que nós tivemos até hoje nós temos um
problema seríssimo com relação a
comportamento social perante a parte de
geração de bens
burocracia Nossa a burocracia é muito
mais elevada que a depor Oi hoje e muito
mais morosa porque as não nós não
tivemos a cobrança de Portugal ter em
relação a se associar a unidade a União
Europeia
os valores éticos sociais
bastantes diferentes cultura hoje
atualmente também muito diferente nós
somos um povo onde sessenta por cento da
população é semianalfabeta
e se pensar em termos de conhecimento
histórico consciência histórica
praticamente não temos nenhuma e justiça
e segurança
e quais são as principais semelhanças o
povo extremamente católico o idioma
apesar de suas diferenças é o mesmo
idioma e esse essa tecnologia nós nossa
relação com Portugal em termos de
tecnologia é pare passo é muito
semelhante e Inclusive eu havia
comentado com a professora é que os meus
parceiros portugueses eu praticamente
todo ano os vezes no Brasil como eu
também vinha Portugal bom Então veja a
relação que existe entre pessoas na área
de tecnologia entre Portugal e Brasil é
muito grande principalmente relacionado
a interesse dos acadêmicos
é porque eu escolhi Portugal para viver
em investir primeiro a música de raízes
nós brasileiros eu não sei quem foi o
meu
tataravô e tataravô que se fala em
Portugal depois do bisavô até o bisavô
eu sei o tá travando eu não sei quem foi
então quando eu vir a Portugal para
resgatar informação a respeito do meu
avô que nascer
1889 aqui em Portugal eu senti uma
emoção muito grande
nós não temos raízes as raízes estão
aqui ó a servir de facilitador na
cooperação tecnológica hora é eu nas
vendas que eu estive em Portugal eu
percebi que algumas coisas aqui seria
interessante no Brasil e algumas coisas
do Brasil seria muito interessante ser
aplicadas aqui ou seja se eu tivesse
condição ir e a facilidade de integrar
os dois mercados eu certamente teria é o
prazer de ver algum estímulo novo
nascendo na no mercado português e algum
estímulo novo nascendo no mercado
brasileiro o que eu quero dizer o
seguinte intelectualmente nós temos uma
carência que Portugal não têm
operacionalmente Portugal Tem uma
carência que nós não temos a
bom e é maior cultura dos descendentes
porque veja as colônias portuguesas no
Brasil
elas são extremamente receptivas aos
descendentes de portugueses como também
os não descendentes de portugueses
e todas as festas tradicionais de
Portugal São repetidas no Brasil coisa
que a gente não vê é tão intensa nas
colônias italianas e espanholas e
japonesas que são as maiores colônias
depois da colônia portuguesa
e o que vende promissor aos meus
propósitos primeiro que eu tive uma
aceitação muito grande no da sociedade
Portuguesa em relação a minha presença
aqui então isso era uma preensão porque
quando você vem para ficar uma semana ou
ficar 15 dias em volta você não consegue
ter esse sentimento você tem que ficar
mesmo
e essa foi uma constante que eu tive
muita aceitação a relação a presença de
um brasileiro proposto a cooperar na
sociedade portuguesa
adaptação os costumes praticamente
nenhuma porque eu sempre tive todos a
minha formação desde pequeno envolvido
com um tradições portuguesas e veio
minha voz foi uma Imigrante que foi para
o Brasil então esse era carregado
entusiasmo as ideias empreendedoras eu
vejo uma carência muito grande hoje
porque Portugal na época dos
descobrimentos
Portugal era foi responsável por um
terço dos descobrimentos de novos
territórios da Espanha foi responsável
por um texto Português sempre foi um
povo voltado a
empreender a fazer buscas e o mercado
receptiva aos produtos da saúde que a
minha área sente que aqui a gente tem
possibilidade de desenvolver como alguns
correlatos meus da área de pesquisa e
desenvolvimento
portugueses têm suas empresas eu falei
eu vou para lá também
é o que eu sou como pessoa física tenho
65 anos quer dizer uma vasta experiência
com uma empresa bem-sucedida no Brasil
na área de produtos cirúrgico Engenheiro
mestre e doutor em biomateriais
carreira profissional como havia
dividido entre a parte acadêmica e a
parte industrial e muita vontade de
empreender e conquistar isso é o carrego
desde que eu me tornei por gente a minha
avó falava o seguinte filho você tem que
ter e a português um posto de gasolina
uma farmácia e uma padaria estarás bem
para o resto da vida eu não sei Espera
essa minha vocação Mas de qualquer forma
percebi que eu deveria gerar bens e
gerando bens eu consigo minha realizar e
o sonho pelo menos o meu é na realidade
gerar bens que sejam de bom proveito
para a sociedade na qual eu convivo ele
é só um português não de facto que eu
nasci no Brasil mas hoje eu sou
português direito e já foi me dada a
nacionalidade Portuguesa
e ele pensou como pessoa jurídica
nós trabalhamos é uma empresa
recém-nascida já com seus produtos sendo
colocados no mercado e o primeiro
produto que nós colocamos no mercado
hoje foi
t-shirts camisolas e meias e radiadores
de infravermelhos porque eu sempre
achei que ora se o material ele pode
absorver a energia teu exala do corpo e
transformar esse energia em algo bom
para mim seria muito interessante e
nesse sentido comecei a trilhar para ver
as informações que eu conseguiria ter de
benefícios sobre o infravermelho e nós
aí desenvolvemos uma cerâmica que a
impregnada na fibra das camisolas e das
meias e recebe as ondas de calor do
corpo processa uma coisa natural do
próprio composto de cerâmica e devolve
ao corpo na faixa do infravermelho longo
e o benefício de infravermelho é o nosso
corpo com relação à recuperação e tecido
muscular e melhoria de circulação e
outros fatores também inclusive no
alívio de dores é bastante conhecido
então resolver colocar isso como
Primeiro produto a nossa meta seria
colocar outros produtos que vão sendo
gradativamente
favorecidos com relação o que a gente
pretende empreender aqui a essa questão
do vim vi Venci eu vim e vi agora só vou
vencer Quando eu conseguir gerar bens
que possam sair de Portugal e para
outros mercados que não português
trazendo divisas para Portugal
é bom pessoal é no que eu acredito
é é o meu livro de cabeceira são os
poemas de Fernando Pessoa
Oi e eu acredito exatamente
nesse nesse trecho do Fernando Pessoa
e mexe muito comigo agora é infelizmente
Por uma questão de própria experiência
eu acredito mais nas pessoas do que nós
instituições atuais As instituições
estão nos ensinando
a tal ponto e nós estamos envelhecendo
sem poder concretizar os nossos sonhos
não existe um discurso Saramago sobre o
que é democracia e valeria a pena vocês
buscarem ouvir o que ele fala sobre
democracia
e eu acho que as pessoas tem que começar
a se defender de uma forma correr atrás
dos seus sonhos
sejam os esforços que forem necessários
porque são esses sonhos que vão ver
vocês a vida toda a busca de seus sonhos
e que eles sejam concretizados no
momento certo e não contem com as
instituições contem com a força de
vontade de vocês
eu sinto como exemplo as padarias no
Brasil que são as pastelarias aqui
noventa e nove porcento das pastelarias
no Brasil são de portugueses
todas as pastelarias trabalham das 6
horas da manhã às 11 horas da noite de
segunda a segunda não existe feriado não
existe final de semana e na e são os
melhores lugares que as pessoas
encontram para se conciliar no início do
dia antes do trabalho
o final do dia após o trabalho elas
servem perfeitamente com os pontos de
encontros e muitos negócios sai das
conversas destas pastelarias na mão de
quem na mão de português então acho que
existe alguma coisa que rompeu
nesse meio tempo onde Portugal como país
deixou de ser exemplo de conquista de
busca e ele tem que voltar a ser porque
está no nosso sangue
Essa é a mensagem que eu tinha passar
para vocês é e colocar que eu acredito
imensamente imensamente que esse mercado
português vai se aquecer novamente e vai
inibir essa migração de pessoas
especializadas para outros países esse
custo é muito alto para Portugal forma
se pessoas de alto nível E essas pessoas
vão trabalhar em outros e tem que
trabalhar aqui se eu puder mostrar que o
mercado brasileiro e o português tem
grandes chances de se integrar nesse
sentido eu vou ganhar em março
intelectual no meu país de origem
Portugal Brasil e vou oferecer a
Portugal uma massa operacional
Fantástico nós somos 220 milhões de
consumidores
220 milhões consumidores cada vez mais
integrados em redes sociais
ó e esses consumidores estão ávidos por
melhores condições em seus produtos e na
sua qualidade de vida e acho que a parte
intelectual de Portugal tem muito a
oferecer isso aí ao Brasil então
Senhores o
mercado brasileiro e o mercado português
é necessário integração tanto para
realização de vocês como para realização
dos correlatos de vocês no Brasil
Muito obrigado pela atenção e
só disposição mais tarde para cá
[Aplausos]